Marvel has created one of the most lucrative film franchises in history.
The MCU, employes countless crew behind the scenes and is always adding new faces to the lineup.
And there's still so much more to look forward too, with no end in sight.
Old fans and noobs alike all agree that the casting choices have been bang on so far,
making the transition from page to screen a smooth one.
All of the characters on this list are super, but that doesn't mean they're one dimensional
Each one projects strength in their own way,
but Marvel has also given them the opportunity to be powerless too.
Before we jump into the good stuff, we just wanted to thank you for checking out our video.
You could be anywhere in the world, but you're here, with us
and because of that we've got a serious case of the warm and fuzzies.  Awwww
And hey, while you're here can you guess the movie based on these emoji's?
Stay tuned for the answer.
Here are ten Marvel secrets that make their actors look weak.
Chris Evans as Captain America.
By this point audiences are so used to seeing Captain America as a dude who is thoughtful,
noble and has the muscles to back up the title.
And while its great for Chris Evans to have such an important role in the MCU
It's got to be hard to keep up with the workouts.
But Cap wasn't always such a beefcake.  Remember his first movie?
Steve Rogers was not exactly someone you would describe as muscular.
And that is the point, isn't it?
Because the after picture means nothing if you don't get to see the one that came before it
Otherwise he'd just be another Hollywood adonis with mommy issues.
Mickey Rourke as Whiplash.
Mickey has been  around the mountain a couple of times so to speak,
and he's no stranger to playing the terrifying big bad.
The actor has been boxing since he was about 10 years old and has sparred with some of the best.
So theoretically he should be able to take on a silver tongued rich kid. Right?
Well now if he wanted to beat Tony Stark, he probably should have learned how to use a computer
before stepping in the ring.
Iron man is all about his technology,
and clearly the best way to fight fire, is with fire.
So Whiplash, whips up a suit similar to Iron Man's and the two have a rumble.
But in real life, Rourke doesn't know his way around technology at all
and struggled through the entire shoot.
Anthony Hopkins as Odin.
Anthony Hopkins is one of the greatest thespians to ever grace our planet.
The renowned actor has performed in over 130 projects.
He's so good, he could probably make a  statue weep real tears if he wanted to.
While filming a scene for Thor, that's kind-of what happened.
Director Kenneth Branagh asked Hopkins to improvise the speech he gives when
banishing the  titular character from Asguard. And improvise he did.
Not only was the moment electrifying on film but the entire crew hard a hard time keeping their composure.
Many of them cried, and both Chris Hemsworth and Tom Hiddleston
admitted they were on the verge of tears as well.
Robert Downey Junior as Iron Man.
Robert Downey Junior is going to do what he wants. Okay? He's Iron Man.
And if Iron Man wants to hide snacks all over the set
to eat when the cameras are rolling
then that's precisely what God damn Iron Man is going to do.
There is no MCU without him after all.
Low blood sugar isn't a heroic trait, and filming all day and night for months on end
will definitely take it's toll on anyone's body.
So just let the man have his snacks all right?
There's no point in taking them away either,
because finding one hidden treat just means that there are still 99 others you haven't found.
So if Marvel wants this stop,
maybe they should try breaking for lunch occasionally instead....
BOOM
Jeremy Renner as Hawkeye.
Securing the role of Hawkeye, was an uphill climb for Jeremy Renner.
Not only did he have to start doing the super hero workout, but he also had to learn archery.
The majority of audience members probably thought he did a great job
when the character appeared in Thor.
But eagle eyed fans noticed that Renner only shot with his right hand.
Whats the big deal?
Well, Hawkeye is supposed to be ambidexterous,
So the actor hustled and trained with Olympians to learn how to shoot with his left hand as well.
Just to be a little more legit for the next movie.
And that my friends is what we call dedication.
Tidla Swinton as The Ancient One.
Before he got his own movie. Dr Strange was a relatively unknown member of the Marvel canon.
Most movie goers hadn't even heard the name.
But long time fans of the graphic novels could hardly contain their joy.
That is, until some of the casting decisions were revealed.
Audiences were mixed about Benedict Cumberbatch in the titular role.
But the real riots happened after Tilda Swinton was announced to be playing
The Ancient One.
The character is traditionally a Tibetan male.
But Hollywood could not have picked a whiter actress.
And the word white washing got thrown around quite a bit.
So while she might not be a weak performer, she was a weak choice.
Rocket Racoon "Oh.. Yeah"
Vin Diesel as Groot.
Just to be clear, Vin Diesel is not a weak man.
He's shorter than you might think.
And his last name isn't really Diesel.
But nobody is going to call him weak to his face.
Now if you only knew him from his voice work in Guardians of the Galaxy however.
You might say that about his vocabulary.
I AM GROOOOOOOOOOOTTT......
Are about as complex as his dialogue gets.
Now obviously that was a writing choice and not on him,
but if you were looking for a reason to hate on the actor.
You might say it's just another entry on an already shallow resume.
Iron Man. "My Turn"
Terrence Howard as War Machine
Money is a weird thing, and your experience with it
drives more of your behaviour than you might realise.
Its a well known fact, that celebrities get paid a lot.  Specifically actors.
So when one of their names ends up in a headline, stating that they demand more money for a role.
It's all to easy to just roll your eyes.
After the success of the first Iron Man instalment.
Terrence Howard requested a pay bump.
Not only was he denied the raise, he was straight up replaced.
The studio brought Don Cheadle, who has played the role of War Machine ever since.
The swap was played up to make Howard look like the greedy bad guy.
When in reality, that might not have been the case.
Tyre's screech
Loud Crash.
Michael. B. Jordan as The Human Torch, and Jamie Bell as The Thing.
Everyone has something to say about 2015's revamp of the big screen Fantastic Four franchise.
And we're no exception.
Tales of behind the scenes meddling done by the studio are usually to blame
for the movie's poor reception,
and perhaps the most popular excuse for it's failure.
It also tanks the credibility of some of the actors involved.
But it's not actually their fault.
Michael. B . Jordan blew everyone's socks off in Creed.
And lets not forget that Jamie Bell wasn't just in Billy Elliot. He was Billy Elliot.
So if you didn't know anything beyond what was happening on screen
You'd probably think it was just bad acting.
History proves, that couldn't be more wrong.
At least Jordan is getting the opportunity to redeem himself in
the MCU'S upcoming film Black Panther.
Spider-Man. "I've only got one job here today and I gotta impress Mr Stark, so..
I'm really sorry.  What???
Tom Holland as Spider-Man
For a lot of people, age ain't nothing but a number,
and yet Hollywood still gets nervous when it comes to casting a young person.
In an industry where it's impossible to tell anyone's real age from just looking at them,
what's the difference?
When 19 year old Tom Holland was revealed as the next Spider-Man.
The studio was a wee bit nervous that he was too young.
Despite the fact that the character is supposed to look young,
act young and actually be young.
Sure they could of hired someone twice his age
and thrown make up at them until the cows came home.
But audiences aren't stupid
and instead of washing out someone else's performance with special effects.
Casting a kid was probably the right way to go.
What do you think?
Do these actors actually look as weak as we thought?
Or did our analysis miss the mark entirely.
Join your fellow nerds in the conversation below.
And while you're there let us know if you got the correct answer
to the movie emoji.
You can also see our other awesome video's by checking out our
Youtube Channel, and joining the notifications squad.
Thanks for watching